it's all a part of that easy riders and
raging bulls Arab ragtag group of
younger filmmakers like you know Francis
Ford Coppola and George Lucas and Peter
Bogdanovich all those guys we're getting
the chance to make really interesting
movies well I think it started with five
Easy Pieces the same producers I was a
kid and I had a great agent Robert Ray's
on at that time and I just went along
with the wave we were Hurst for two
weeks before we shine a foot so they
were together for a week in LA and a
week in the archon city in Wichita Falls
actually the location gave him a lot of
authenticity because they were in the
town that Larry McMurtry wrote about and
when you're on a distant location
there's no distractions you're not going
to go to the movies you're not going to
have dinner with friends hang out and
they did and they all bonded very
strongly we got down there we were
isolated in that little town and it was
like we're all staying at the Ramada Inn
you know and it's it's uh we're close
we're doing a lot of steamy rehearsals
in the Presidential Suite of the Ramada
in Wichita Falls and it it just came to
life and it felt so real to me I was in
love with everybody every other actor on
the set I thinking the actors were
awfully good the dialogues awfully good
McMurtry is the best regional dialogue
writers since Matt Mark Twain I think
generally speaking I loved
films because it removes distractions
eye color skin color hair color and so
the focus is more on the acting and the
dramatic and aspects of it that's one
reason the other thing is it's easier to
convey the period if it's a
black-and-white period which the early
50s was still sort of black and white
was Roberts thirties was the unsung hero
of enemies he photographed them and
without Robert searches it would have
never looked that way this is for me
this was somewhat of a painful
experience to tell you the truth it was
very close to what I was going through
at home the divorce of my mom and my dad
and what's that song Ringo Starr you
know I'll play the part of a guy who's
sad and lonely and all I got to do is
act naturally that pretty much that
pretty much puts it into a wall nutshell
for you well when I first read the part
of JC I was very insulted that someone
would think that I was like that I I did
see it was a great part and I was not
gonna turn it down but later on in life
you know I realized I was a lot more
like JC
than I ever want to imagine because I
did do terrible things to men without
any thought about the consequences and I
broke a lot of hearts and I think at a
certain point in my life after I'd had
my heart broken plenty of times that I
had been more like JC and and but
sometimes you know you you see yourself
in somebody but you never want to admit
it sometimes it takes a little few years
of wisdom I'm not like JC anymore Oh too
bad
the power just reduced was more
important than
than anything because if you see JC
doesn't really have a very good time
sexually she kind of gets the short
another stick so to speak I've played
about 300 songs of the era of the period
and chose the ones that I would thought
were right for the scenes and ones that
I thought I wouldn't get tired of
hearing if you had a movie score
you know how score is so often you look
back at an old film and you go I can
tell when that was made but a Peter was
brilliant with his use of music the
original music of the period and often I
used music as a counterpoint obviously
if it's a sad scene I didn't use the sad
song I had an up-tempo song and vice
versa the town was the domain character
I mean everybody in it was just like the
town everybody had their own life they
were unhappy of where they were no
matter if they were rich or poor regrets
I think the only character in the whole
film that was really happy to the whole
film was my brother Sam his he they
didn't think much he was just happy to
sweep the street it's ironic that in
life to go through a scene where you
actually have somebody die and you hold
him and then to do it in real life makes
you really wonder about who we are what
is this experience that we're living
that's that's the hardest thing for me
but I know he's with us and he did some
great films and good kid I loved him you
know I was just I was born the year went
to the theaters and yeah so it's one of
those things where I probably would have
been 14 or 15 and really just seemed
like a great movie and then just certain
things like it coming from a novel and
being black and white you might not
think it's the kind of thing that would
appeal to a kid like that but yeah it
was just really kind of effect on me
I could I was just felt like I was the
luckiest person alive to have had this
opportunity to be in a film like this to
have my first acting teacher be pagane
[ __ ] and have actors of this caliber
play opposite I mean I think I had the
right look at the right time and like I
say I think I'm the luckiest person
alive to have had an opportunity to be a
part of something like this